one other thing I will say about this
show is I like how you know obviously
everyone's thinking about the Mr Beast
version and it's just like I think when
he did it you know it was we even
probably said this like it was like you
know I just seemed like the most
impressive thing ever and how could you
get better than this he remade squid
games yeah like you know he spent so
much money yeah and then you realize
this comes out and you're like oh
there's levels to this [__] and there
always will be you know like YouTube
will always always kind of be yeah you
can as much as you want be like YouTube
is the new you know it's it's not the
new landscape it's like it's not it's
not like you don't need these big
production
companies it's like this is a whole it's
like they've remade the [__] show
like scene by scene but made it real
yeah which is awful cuz this like
conversation right here just sounds like
bowing to your corporate Overlord being
like which I'm not trying to do I think
that both have a place totally totally
like Mr BEAST's video ended up being a
different thing right he's like walking
around interviewing people on the floor
right it's like much less polished
reality show by Design but still when
this came out I think a lot of people
were like this is the most impressive
thing you could do yeah in this vein and
it's like
no it's not yeah if you get the most
evil people on Earth they can make
something even more evil
exactly we oh oh you wanted to see
people suffer yeah that's what Netflix
said they're like oh no problem mhm oh
we got that send us a one minute video
and then cuz that's what the application
says send a one minute video telling us
about yourself they got that lady in the
beginning was like I really just want to
make rent and the casting director's
like oh perfect yeah pause it we don't
have to see anymore pause it that's all
we need to know right there wait just
play what else does she say just want to
know what it's like to pay off my car
pause it oh God say less not be more
perfect say less say less on the board
number one I want to meet her when she
walks through the door yeah cuz she's
going out first I want to shake her hand
I want to shake her hand we're going to
put Vaseline on her shoes yeah yeah man
please upload a one minute video telling
us about yourself why you want to be on
squid game The Challenge what your game
plan would be and what you would do with
a huge $4.5 million cash prize if you
won as if any story that they get isn't
going to be like so brutal yeah yeah hi
I've got a I've got a mother in hospice
and I just like to spend one more year
with her yeah how dark is it the cast
director is like yeah we're going to
take that yeah that's what we like to
hear right oh yeah suffering oh yeah
let's get it and here we are yucking it
up being like this is the greatest show
ever cuz it's it's [__] up cuz yeah
yeah yeah this is the closest we're
going to get to Hunger Games no but I
think I think it's not our fault I think
it's the fault besides people being
hungry sorry go ahead yeah
yeah uh it's not our fault I think it's
the fault of the reality TV like um
Paradigm in the United States where like
for the last 20 years it's been this
like find the person with the [__] up
story yeah tug at the heartstrings and
then give them the big payoff when they
finally win in the end you know tug on
their heartstrings tug on their heart
string this my heart string yeah Tu on
your heart on my heart string yeah Tu on
my heart
string oh man that tugs on my hard
string just just like you say hard
string yeah what do you mean that's how
d reality TV we just tug on our penis
and cry yeah I can't believe they lost
the bachelor biggest cash prize in
reality show history
wo yeah is Netflix doing this because
they need writeoffs
the stock price is uh getting hit pretty
hard we need a big write off here no
dude they probably just they had a bunch
of money to blow during the strike
they're like we can't buy anything
nothing's going on so it's like what do
we do with all this money I don't know
what if we did squid games in real life
like Mr Beast yeah yeah but like we get
the best
cinematographers we we get
listen I know some guys that did
National Geographic we'll get these
[__] Buffalo running shots we'll get
them like the animals they are yeah they
definitely did they definitely did get
some like some good you know close-ups
as the money was falling into the bin of
people be like yeah so Grim like just
Grim just gross shots of people be like
yeah oh my god oh just you wait brother
just you wait and every time someone
dies they have a clip of someone saying
that's $10,000 more dollars
yeah the editing is so good on that yeah
I know just you wa
brother um so you haven't seen the
carrot scene I love the the uh the
mullet guy oh which one the the first
the one from Kansas City yeah in the
first in his like talking head interview
and he's like h hot cousin
Hunter not Hunter Biden like Hunter
Biden what I guess it kind of look like
um no when he was like everyone sees the
mullet and thinks I'm more or less
intelligent than them yeah like well
you're not really helping your case more
or less intelligent than them oh no
you're talking about the guy with the
glasses yeah with the glasses yeah oh
that dude's from Kentucky oh he yeah
yeah that other guy does look like
Hunter yeah that's if Hunter like played
lacrosse yeah yeah and thought drawing
pictures was weird
yeah his [__] was funny too in the very
beginning where he's like it's me and my
brother man I think it's going to be us
to the end no it is not personality it's
just him looking at him like oh [__] oh
[__] man that's my boy right there what
the [__] yeah so watch the show it's
[__]
good and uh we will be auditioning for
season two for
sure for sure we'd be [__] in there
man yeah do you want to record one
minute videos each real
quick
um yeah if we actually send them in why
don't we just do it in the wide and we
just do a one minute with the two of us
yeah the two of us
yeah all right ready here's our here's
our audition wait put put some dramatic
Lighting on hi hi big big fans of the
show huge fans of the show we run a kill
shelter and we're tired of doing it
it's a human kill shelter yeah for old
people yeah and uh yeah it just we're
sick of doing it it's hard yeah what's
your name by the way my name is Noel and
mine's Cody from the tiny meat gang
podcast it's awful having to shoot these
old people right between their eyes we
use the same gun that they use for cows
for beef you know it's got like that
Hemi
combustion that cylinder that's what we
have to do between the eyes we don't
have much time left left look if you
would consider us to be on squid Games
The Challenge season 2 um you would you
would greatly change our lives what our
strategy would be uh would be to jerk
off in the bunks
separately every night we try in other
people's no we try to we each get our
own top bunk yeah and we try to jerk it
every night yeah and um we made the song
Walkman oh that's the end oh G some more
Contex so just in case I want to check
it
out popular songs like 90 92 million
streams or something like that so check
it out dude dude could you
imagine all like 400 people in
there in the middle of the night just
one of the the top of the bunk it's
just no it's just like it's just
vibrating and the bunks four three and
two are like what the
hell what hey who's checking the the
bunk stop shaking the bunk stops for a
[Laughter]
second oh my God oh my God are you
jacking off up there
no yeah no dude hey hey hey you
[Music]
jack me me me oh he's sleeping okay
[Laughter]
okay that'd be crazy
man or just un just without a care in
the
world yeah [__] yeah I'm just trying to
get this nut off before I go to bed
sorry only way only way sleep yeah got
get the guy next to you hey man you
don't
mind oh
sorry I got to take a
[__] just ass naked in the public men's
[__] toilet just jacking off sorry
man I really got to take a come hey when
you got to go you got to go sorry
brother you know how it is sorry man
duty calls got to take a come real fast
you know how it goes Buddy he's got to
empty your little Willie
yeahh
you got to H to your little Willie
sometimes you know on your
knees knees up on the toilet
seat pointing it
[Laughter]
down